i'll write on my stuff myself when i'm
upset so much you know
i do that just to just
it
kind of takes takes away anger problems
if i do that
and i think wait i can get rid of my
anger
but
i know i shouldn't ride on myself but i
just get rid of my
my temper
and i hate get have to get rid of my
temper
like that
all right maria yeah maria where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
doddridge county
what it's in western area
of west virginia yeah
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
yeah i had my mom and dad but they
they looked at me like weird looking
like because of because of my preference
say they they agree with it and i wanted
to be who i was
and every time i one video was they
judge me say oh you're not you're not a
girl you're not a girl yeah yeah i am
i'm a girl once i know i am
and they just
kept judging me being judgmental
you knew this at what age
when i was real young was in grade
school i started realizing it
and they
kept
judgment on me because i wanted to wear
my mom's high heels and
clothes that she had
and i got tired of being judged by it
it's not funny to be judged by a judge
for it sure
it's
makes me feel bad along your judge
you left home at what age
what was
around my 20s
20s or 30s so you made it through high
school
yeah
how were your school years
um
i got judged in school
but i know they i know they knew that i
was different you picked them yeah i
knew they knew i was different because i
didn't have a girlfriend and
they knew i wasn't that wasn't like
anyone else
and that's why i was so vulnerable
to it to getting judged
do you have friends as a kid
yeah i had friends
i had
there's one that was miami but he uh my
sworn enemy but he uh took up from one
day
i got sucker punched in the gut and
knocked all the air on me he he
protected me
he told him to pick on somebody their
own damn size
and then there's a girl that was my best
friend
she was tall
and she she took up for me
a lot
and a few times i had to fight in school
because of it
i hated it
i don't like fighting
your family didn't didn't
didn't accept you uh-uh
but they loved me but they didn't accept
me for what i was
that's the only problem with it you know
i lost my mom in 2020 and my dad in 2021
same month and month of may lost him
sorry
and
even though i had
kind of had a little bit of hatred in my
heart because of the judgmentalness but
i still loved them
i kind of had a little bit hatred too
because of all that
now stayed with some friends and sell
them
and lived with them for a little while
until i went to clarksburg
then i went to that uh clarksburg
mission for like uh
like a rehab thing but that didn't work
but
i can do better on my own
than i can with some place like that
because that stuff don't work for me
it's not and it's not very often that
i get into into doing something that i
shouldn't be doing but
i do
every once in a blue moon
it's a feel bad
and what kind of things will you do
a little i do just a smidge of meth
every once wild just to calm down
just enough to call my nerves
and i've got to do something
just calm down
i really should get back on on that
medicine i was taken
what medicine were you taking
hydroxyzine and another one for anxiety
and
depression and that hormone medicine i
should get back on that too
you were taking hormones yeah
female hormones yeah
i felt better
but you stopped all of that yeah
which i shouldn't have
it's missed me it messed me up my
hormones it's messing them up because of
that
so now you're living on the streets yeah
in downtown charleston yeah
what's that like yeah
it's rough
you gotta watch your stuff
uh people theft you
and then you gotta replace clothes
this and that
they they because they thief because
there's a bunch of these out there you
gotta watch
you get you get uh beating up on the
street at all
uh not here i haven't but morgantown i
did
what kind of stuff happened
uh some i was asleep underneath a set of
steps
just sound asleep and they threw a rock
and hit me in their throat
and then they hit me in the shoulder
hit me behind my shoulder blade
and then they punched me inside the head
they tried to kill me
what they tried to do
and there's nothing i could do about it
i was trying to get away from them and
they still followed me four ways
and i didn't appreciate it
being followed like that
and it gets pretty old
and going to the police isn't really an
option
they won't really do much
about that
police they're they're like uh there's
not much we can do
that's our excuse
because all of them told me said you
might as well not go to cops because
they won't they don't want they don't
help you out
because uh cause
because of being being gay and
everything you they don't want to you
they don't want to help you too much do
you feel like you're unwelcome here
somewhat
but somewhat that way
but i feel more
uh
accepted here but i feel a little bit
unwanted too
that's
now in that place they're probably
pretty close-minded to this lifestyle
right yeah
yeah especially when i came out of the
closet long time ago it just
i came out and just
just be myself
who had a bigger problem with it your
mom or your dad
well
there's
pretty much both of them
they
they didn't they didn't like who i was
and i wanted to be a cheerleader when i
was in school
i wanted to dress just like i dress now
in school but they won't they wouldn't
let me
i had i had a right to
if i wanted to do
it's my ever right to be like who i was
who i am
but
they didn't won't let me
and you were you were born this way
nothing yeah nothing happened to you as
a child
nobody no sexual abuse right now
[Music]
do you have friends today yeah you do
yeah i got friends people on the street
yeah
i made more friends on the street than i
have at a shelter
and because i'm out about i can be
have friends around
that actually care more about me
than in a shelter
you have brothers and sisters i got a
half brother half sister
got another half sister which i don't
know where she is
do you feel like you have any family to
go to now or i don't know i haven't
contacted him for a long time
and
i'm considering like an aunt to
two kids two or three kids
my sisters but i don't know if she'll
accept me if i if i call her
i don't know
i'm afraid she'll be unacceptant about
me
that's my problem
contacting her
and i don't want to contact her because
of that
i'm afraid to it scares me to contact
her
because of the rejection yeah
yep that's what what what extends to
rejection yeah it's horrible
and
what kind of emotions do you go through
unwantedness
like people just
not wanting to want me around no more
wanting to shove me out of town
a few times
this and that
that's the way i feel sometimes
and i don't like i don't like that
feeling yeah you get depressed or yeah
yeah
yeah i get pretty depressed bad
sometimes
it's the worst it's the worst feeling to
have sometimes
when you get like that yeah do you ever
get an opportunity to talk about these
things with anyone uh
that one i'm friends with that ashley
i'm friends with
she understands
she's
she's pretty understanding
and she helps me as much she can
and i'm glad she's there for me
because if it was for her
and some other transgender friends and
all that i wouldn't really probably
wouldn't have very many people talk to
it wasn't for that
you ever been loved
i've seen a few guys i like but that
tracked my attention
and i messed around with a few
yeah i was in i was in backseat a
vehicle with some guy
enjoy it
and then there's a guy down to vice
versa down here in morgantown
he can't keep his hands off me i
couldn't keep my hands off him about i
wish
that i could have had him
but there's somebody got in too big a
rush with me
that
that wanted right now and i'm like this
is too fast
i don't want to go this fast i want to
take it take it slow and easy
not not
not right off the bat
it just aggravates me when someone wants
to go like real fast like
you're not that kind of girl uh-uh nope
and your drug use is not something
that's out of control uh-uh it's not
even out of control
i don't quit anytime at once just every
once in a great blue moon once in blue
moon i do
do do want to calm down a little bit
because i feel better if i calm down
what was the roughest part of your life
yeah
living through
well
living with my mom and dad was because
that's my roughest part because i wanted
to be who i was and they wouldn't let me
that's pretty rough
and i i wanted to
express myself who i am
and
when you can't express yourself that
that's not that's not good when you
can't express yourself
it's it you need to be able to express
yourself the person needs to be able to
and show your true callers who you are
but people are certain people that won't
let you do it
and i hate it when they do that
and
every once in great well i'll go to
church every once in a while
try it helps me out a little bit
there's one church i go to i know that
they're accepting
is the nitro church down here ward in
charleston on the west side
they're accepting of me
it's nice i appreciate that
that they are
you're living on the streets
yeah it's got to affect you how do you
think you've changed from living
homeless like this uh
more more sensitive
sometimes more moody
uh
i feel like i probably need to get back
on my meds again
i was on
and
that that helped me out fall back i was
back on my meds
sure
it helped me out a lot
do you have dreams of doing something
with your life
i had dreams of going
doing drag doing dragon stuff dropped
being drag queen oh really i had dreams
of that
we're working out we're working out that
gay boy down there
i had dreams of that so there's a game
right here yeah
lee street lounge yeah
and i had dreams of working there
at a place like that
but i know that it's dangerous
at night when you come back from a place
like that
because there's people out at night you
gotta watch them
when they know you work somewhere like
that
and that's when you gotta watch yourself
because you'll get watch yourself that
you're not gonna get attacked by
somebody
by the wrong because wrong people
see you constantly coming in and out of
the bar
working at a place like that and uh
you never know what they're going to try
you just don't know
what are you afraid of what are you most
afraid of in your life
i'm getting attacked one of these days
yeah
because sooner or later it's gonna be
somebody won't attack me again
sooner or later
it's like they got a got like a
i kind of put like a
like a
like a bounty in your head that some of
these people do when they want to attack
you like that
because because of the preference and
this and that
it's like they they want to do something
and it's not it's not right
that people want to attack people or or
judge you like that it's not right at
all
that's kind of people that you don't
want to be around
that want to judge you
for who you are
and when they judge it's just like
why are you judging me for
uh
you shouldn't have you don't want the
right to do that
just because of who i am
there's it's stupid
stupidity what it is
it's a hate crime
[Music]
and
they don't
realize when they do a hate crime that
they can't get in trouble for it
for hate crimes
and that's
that's why i hate hate crimes
what was your favorite memory
uh
going down and vice versa
which is a gay club yeah
in where in morgantown yeah
[Music]
i enjoyed it
i got a lot of friends there's a few
friends out there they're drag queens
and i'm best friends with those drag
queens
they're not they're nice people
and the reason why i was going through
uh hormone therapy was i was going
through a whole transition
from from uh male to female
let's go that's how i want to do that
and i am going to change my name when i
first get chance
to maria
it's going to be changed what was your
name as a man ira dallas morrison
what's your first name ira
ira oh ira yeah
and i want to
change my name
and
start a whole new life
with a new name
and just start over again
i feel better if i start over
you're happier yeah as a as a woman yeah
would you describe yourself as happy in
general
yeah you seem to be pretty happy yeah
i'm happy i just i just don't like being
judged that's the same thing
otherwise that i'm happy
wasn't it i mean
but yeah but what can you say about
people
people they
judge you
they say things
they
and you can't really stop them
when they do that
that's the worst part
it'd be nice if you'd stop them but
yeah
not them you can't
do you have any role models as a kid
that you looked up to uh
like i mean pop rock singers and stuff
well anything yeah lady gaga madonna and
some other ones
i mean relatives or friends or anybody i
didn't really have any uh role models
as relatives as friends but
but the ones that was lady gaga and some
of the pop rock singers
it's only the ones that has my role
models
there's more proteges that i really
respected
their style
style and the way they dressed
is sex work ever been a thing that you
you've
done
uh-uh
but i've been
been thinking about doing that makes
make a little bit money i've been
thinking about it i could have made some
money by doing that
i had people come me offering me to pay
me
which
i can make probably make 50 60 70 bucks
or more by doing that
have you ever traveled
i've been to indiana one time
not very i think it's huntington or
something like that to where the bowling
alleys are and stuff
wasn't in school been there that's about
it then places
otherwise nat i haven't been really no
other place
there's a whole world out there yeah
you ever think of moving yeah
where would you go
san diego california or
san francisco
[Music]
where the where there's a whole
community gay community it's just places
you probably probably find it a little
more accepting too yeah
yeah that's why that's why i like to go
somewhere like that
where it's more accepting and
it won't be judged hardly
but it's more dangerous in the cities
but yeah it's warmer in the winter yeah
but it's a little bit
yeah but the danger is a little higher
but
i i won't worry about that as long as i
was in community of people my people
down there that's you know i'd be happy
that'd be a nice place to go to sure
it's good to visit just to see if you
like it yeah
yeah it would
and go somewhere like that and be like
the heck with uh west virginia
i don't
not come back to west virginia unless i
just visit
otherwise than that no not to live here
there's no way i won't live here harley
i've been wanting to get out west
virginia for years
yeah traveling would probably be good
for you
yeah
have you had jobs uh i worked at sawmill
for a while
to our gut harassed and
this and that
i can tell that happened
and then i
worked
for somebody done since construction
he got in hurries rushes
and i told him i said you know what the
heck with you
i thought my mama said you know what
tell him i'm not here
because he got into bigger hurries
and that's the only problem with him
and then
then odd jobs
my my cousin
i worked with him in all jobs and then
then his wife was judgmental
on me but he wasn't he he accepted me
but his wife didn't really accept me
hardly that much
other than that that it's it's pretty
good with my cousin
that's
i wish life life was a lot better yeah
but
but you can't help it
when it's like this when it's
a very judgmental world
you can't really help nothing like that
do you feel like life is unfair
yeah
because you're not judging anyone you're
not you're not mean to anyone nope
i'm not mean to nobody i treat people
good
i treat them right
and
i try not to
to have hate hatred towards anybody i
try not to but today it's just like
seemed like it come out of me a little
bit
towards a few people yeah you're in a
darker darker mood today
yeah
and i hate being like that
i don't like being like that
makes me makes me feel bad when i get
like that
and i
it's
rough when when a person's like that
it's like
like
don't don't try not to be like that
try be a nice person today
try at least
try to be a good girl try to be good
don't be mean to nobody
but when they start on you you can't
you can't be nice to some people
that's a problem some people it's
you can't it's hard to be nice to any
you know any of them
because they start fights with you
what's that it's something that i don't
know what
i don't know what to do about sometimes
it's about that stuff
and
wasn't that i'm just
and i love that transgender music
it's
speaks to me
and there's uh one song lady gaga made
it's it's maybe i'm born this way that
song was made for us
that song was
it's it's because i had a thing and said
don't be dragged be a queen
i respect that song
it's
and there's a lot there's a few people
who made songs like that
pop rock singers did
that that's respectful to us
but yeah but well
if
i just wish people if people would be
nicer
and not judge a book by its cover
but by its pages
they'd be better off
if they do it that way
because that's what they're doing to us
they don't look at the big picture
and look at our personalities
and how nice we are they don't look at
that stuff
they look at everything
horrible towards us
because there's people that call there's
people that calls names all time
they they call they call us sometimes
pedophiles this that we're not
they give us bad they give us a bad rep
when they do that that's all they're
doing
and it's it's
the dumbest thing they're doing is
doing it to us
and it's just oh
i can't can't help but what they do
is that a hatred in the world yeah a lot
of it
too much hatred in this world
not enough love in this world
absolutely
all right maria thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome it's
nice talking with you it's good to talk
to you too thank you very much
you